hey Vsauce Michael here and Jake and
Kevin and we are in Santa Monica which
of course means that the V and Vsauce
will stand for the Roman numeral v as in
five questions from you guys our first
question comes from knotch he didn't ask
this of me in particular but I love how
non-intuitive
the answer is assume an earth that's
perfectly spherical and a rope stretched
around the equator snugly what would
happen if that rope was just say six
meters longer six meters is it very much
but because of the relationship between
a circumference and a radius six meters
of extra rope would allow the entire
rope to not fit snugly around the earth
but one meter above it all the way
around that's cool but what if instead
of a rope we used something more rigid
like a structure a bridge and we built
the bridge all the way around the earth
and then all at once destroyed its
supports would it float clearly the
Earth's gravity would pull the structure
down but down is in the opposite
direction for the other side of the
bridge well it turns out such a scenario
would be incredibly unstable Earth's
gravity isn't equal everywhere and if
you follow at tweat sauce you saw some
great graphs showing just how much
gravity changes simply based on the
density of rock below when you factor in
the Sun and the moon you wind up with a
bridge structure that is not gonna stay
where it is if the bridge itself was
indestructible it would start violently
hula-hooping around the earth crushing
things but there's no known material
strong enough to do that instead you
would wind up with bridge pieces flying
everywhere a sphere around the earth
would be a bit more stable but a ring
not so much the ring even if spinning
would rapidly break apart into smaller
pieces
last week you guys asked me a question
that I have always wondered let's say I
was
stranded in the mountains waiting for
rescuers to arrive but it was going to
take a while I had plenty of snow and
plenty of water but I was hungry dying
of starvation would it make sense to
amputate one of my legs and eat it I
mean it kind of makes sense right
I'd have my entire leg to eat his food
which would probably fill me up and I
would have one less limb that I would
need to keep alive the only problem is
that the trauma your body would endure
from the loss of a limb would greatly
exceed the benefit you would get by
eating the food you're better off
keeping that limb on your body because
your body's process of using reserves of
energy is more efficient than the
process of digestion so keep the leg on
and let it wither away keeping you alive
don't cut it off and eat it and digest
it how does hare know when to stop
growing it's good question because the
hair on my arm which there's a lot of
never grows any longer than this and if
I were to shave my arm off it would grow
back and stop right where it is right
now but head hair is different for
instance my hair what's left of it would
keep growing if I didn't cut it but no
other animal has that situation you
don't see wolves out in the forest
saying wow look how long my hair is
getting I better get to the barber shop
so why do humans have head hair that
grows so long but body hair elsewhere
that stops seemingly right when it's
supposed to well first things first the
hair on your head will not keep growing
forever typically around 6 years of
growth is the limit when hair grows it
is in what is known as its antigen phase
and fur hair on your head that phase can
last
to six years but the anagen phase of
hair elsewhere on your body
eyebrows eyelashes is much shorter
except in cases like this guy whose
eyebrows grow like head hair and have
allowed him to set the world record for
longest eyebrows humans probably lost
their fur coats their thick body hair
because it didn't really help us hunting
and running around sweating on the
savanna and unlike other animals us
humans had discovered fire and could
make clothing to keep ourselves warm
without meeting a built-in fur coat to
be sure long hair that falls over your
ears and neck can keep you warmer but
leading theories also argue that long
head hair may be our fault a result of
the fact that early humans picked mates
that could grow longer hair on their
heads mates that could do that were
probably healthier and in colder
climates literally had a built-in hat to
keep their body warm one of the
questions I get the most is about eye
fluids those little dots or squiggles
that you see in your vision especially
when looking at a bland scene like the
clear blue sky eye floaties are made out
of little fibrils that occur in your eye
as you age and you can't look directly
at them because they're inside the fluid
of your eye
turning your eye to look at them simply
causes the fluid to move and the
floating as well but the thing about eye
floaties that I love the most is that
they are almost always microscopic you
can't see them with the naked eye except
when they are inside your eye if you
were to pull a knife floaties out you
wouldn't be able to see it but in your
eye it's close enough to the retina to
leave a shadow on the retina and that's
what you see when you see eye floaties
finally how much would Wikipedia way if
I printed all the text out and bound it
into books well luckily there's a
pedia article about this very topic the
english-language wikipedia contains
about two billion three hundred and
forty five million words which if
printed at the density of the
Encyclopedia Britannica would equal
about 1759
volumes which would look like this
altogether they would weigh about 7,000
pounds if you're between the ages of 13
and 18 you may want to check out the
Google science fair it's an amazing
competition these guys are great they
actually helped make that Earth Bridge
animation for me so be sure to check out
Google science fair dot-com and I'll
keep checking out Los Angeles I'm here
with Kevin and jake from vsauce3 for the
first time ever the three of us have
never been in one location
simultaneously until now so be sure
you're subscribed to us because amazing
videos will come soon and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]